From PRI, Public Radio International. From PRI, Public Radio International. From PRI, Public Radio International. Public Radio. Public Radio International.
来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。公共广播。国际公共广播电台。
What could be more horrible than the moment when you realize that everybody in the world can see some aspect of you, something about you, that you never even knew that you were revealing, that you didn't want to reveal? So Mubarak was at a track meet-- this is back in high school-- he was at this track meet, and he was setting up those runners' blocks you use in track.
有什么比意识到全世界都能看到你身上的某个方面——你甚至不知道自己正在流露的、也不想流露的东西——那一刻更可怕的呢？穆巴拉克当时正在参加一场田径比赛——那是他高中时的事——他当时正在设置田径比赛用的起跑器。
And I was sort of pampering my blocks, moving the blocks back and forth ever so slightly, hair lengths, testing out how they felt and standing up and putting my hands on my hip and putting my finger on my cheek and looking at it as if I was in deep thought. And bending down and probably even dusting off the blocks.
我当时有点在“呵护”我的起跑器，把它们前后挪动一点点，调整距离，测试脚感，然后站起来，双手叉腰，手指放在脸颊上，表现出深思熟虑的样子。然后弯下腰，可能还会拍掉起跑器上的灰尘。
What I didn't know at the time was there was the whole group of track members from the opposing team who were standing, watching me, and laughing. They were like, this big sissy is what they're putting up for us to beat?
我当时不知道的是，有一群来自对方球队的田径队员正站着看我，还在笑。他们说，这就是他们派出来跟我们比赛的那个大娘娘腔？
Remember, please, high school. High school, where, in the hierarchy of put downs, the worst thing you could call a boy was "sissy." Mubarak won his match.
请记住，这是高中。在高中，在各种贬低人的等级里，你给男生起的最难听的外号就是“娘娘腔”。穆巴拉克赢得了他的比赛。
And the coach came up after I won, and he actually gave me this big hug. And he was like, "That was great." And I was like, "Thanks." But my time wasn't anything particularly better than before. So I kind of had this puzzled look in his face. And he's like, "That was great the way you psyched those guys out by acting like a big sissy in front of your blocks and then showing them." And as soon as he said that, it hit me, what had happened. And I was like-- I played along. "Yeah, hey, good thing I thought of that."
我赢了之后教练走过来，真的给了我一个大大的拥抱。他说：“干得好。”我说：“谢谢。”但我的成绩并没有比之前好多少。所以我脸上露出困惑的表情。他说：“你刚才在起跑器前装成一副大娘娘腔的样子，然后打败了他们，这招真高明。”他一说完，我就明白了发生了什么。我说——我顺着他的话演了下去。“是啊，嘿，幸好我想到了这一招。”
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Sissies. Weak ones, defiant ones, brave ones, and the ones who do not even know they are a sissy. Act One, Anti-Oedipus.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是：娘娘腔。弱小的、叛逆的、勇敢的，以及那些甚至不知道自己是娘娘腔的人。第一幕，反俄狄浦斯。
Act Two, Instructions for Sissies.
第二幕，娘娘腔指南。
Act Three, The Pansy Kings Sing Songs of Love.
第三幕，三色堇之王唱响爱之歌。
Act Four, syndicated columnist Dan Savage answers the question, who loves a sissy? He does. Stay with us.
第四幕，联合专栏作家丹·萨维奇回答一个问题：谁会爱上一个娘娘腔？他会。请继续收听。
Act One. Well, the tragedy of the story of Oedipus, if you remember this from school, is that a son kills his father and marries his mother and then, of course, rips out his eyes when he realizes what it is that he's done. And the thing about this story is that he does all these things unwittingly. He doesn't know that that's what he's doing with his mother and father when he does it.
第一幕。好吧，俄狄浦斯故事的悲剧在于，如果你还记得学校里学过的，就是一个儿子杀死了他的父亲，娶了他的母亲，然后当然，当他意识到自己做了什么时，他挖出了自己的双眼。这个故事的关键在于，他所做的一切都是在不知情的情况下发生的。当他对自己母亲和父亲做出那些事时，他并不知道自己是在做什么。
Well, the first story on today's program is also about a family that ends up getting ripped apart. It's also about a family where the son ends up with the mother, the father gone. And it's also a story where the tragedy of it is that it all happens without any of them really wanting it to happen this way. It's the ending they all wanted to avoid. Nancy Updike prepared this story of an American family and of what it means to be a man.
今天节目的第一个故事也关于一个最终分崩离析的家庭。它也关于一个儿子最终和母亲生活在一起，而父亲已经不在了。这同样是一个悲剧故事，因为这一切发生时，他们之中没有人真正希望事情变成这样。这是他们都想避免的结局。南希·厄普代克准备了这个关于美国家庭以及何谓男人的故事。
This story is like one those Russian dolls where there's always a smaller one inside. The smallest doll, the core of the drama, is the fact that Mubarak, a childhood sissy, grew up to be a different kind of sissy than his father. His father is nerdy and bookish. Mubarak's gay.
这个故事就像那些俄罗斯套娃，里面总有一个更小的。最小的那个娃娃，也就是戏剧的核心，是穆巴拉克这个从小就是娘娘腔的孩子，长大后成了与他父亲不同类型的娘娘腔。他父亲是书呆子气很重的人。而穆巴拉克是同性恋。
Everything around that core gets bigger and bigger until finally you can't believe the biggest and the smallest have anything to do with each other, the one is so bloated and the other so tiny.
围绕着这个核心的一切变得越来越大，直到最后你无法相信最外层和最内层有什么关系，一个如此肿胀，另一个又如此渺小。
At the beginning of this story, Mubarak's parents are married and in love, and both prepared to live far from everything they know to be with each other. At the end of the story, they may still be in love, but they're divorced and an ocean apart and not speaking. And Mubarak is caring for his mother the way a husband might.
在这个故事的开头，穆巴拉克的父母结婚并相爱，两人都准备离开他们所熟悉的一切去陪伴对方。在故事的结尾，他们可能仍然相爱，但他们已经离婚，远隔重洋，互不往来。而穆巴拉克正像丈夫一样照顾着他的母亲。
OK, Margie Ruth.
好了，玛姬·露丝。
Now, don't get it too hot.
别弄得太烫了。
I'm not going to get it too hot.
我不会把它弄得太烫的。
Mubarak starts Margie's shower, and he's holding on to her so she won't fall. And she's holding on to him too. She's about five feet tall, naked, and fragile looking, and very pale. He's dressed in jeans and a shirt that he knows are about to get really wet.
穆巴拉克开始给玛姬洗澡，他扶着她以免她摔倒。她也扶着他。她大约五英尺高，赤身裸体，看起来很脆弱，脸色非常苍白。他穿着牛仔裤和衬衫，他知道这些衣服很快就会完全湿透。
All right, lift your breasts. Lift one at a time so I can wash under it.
好了，抬起你的乳房。一次抬一个，这样我可以洗下面。
Hey, Margie, was it hard the first time Mubarak gave you a shower?
嘿，玛姬，穆巴拉克第一次给你洗澡时，你觉得难为情吗？
I got embarrassed.
我很尴尬。
How did you get over being embarrassed?
你是怎么克服这种尴尬的？
I don't know. Just because it happens over and and over again. Mubarak is my son, you know?
我不知道。只是因为这事情反复发生。穆巴拉克是我儿子，你知道吗？
He gets a washcloth in under her breasts, and she stands serenely, blinking in the water. It's a moment so intimate it's hard to watch. But then, as he gets her out of the shower and is drying her off, there's another moment that makes the intimacy of everything before it seem completely beside the point and prettied up in comparison. He takes a baby wipe and wipes her butt for her.
他把毛巾塞到她乳房下，她平静地站着，在水里眨着眼睛。那一刻亲密到令人难以直视。但随后，当他把她从淋浴间扶出来并为她擦干时，又有另一个时刻，让之前所有的亲密感相比之下显得微不足道且被粉饰过了。他拿出一张婴儿湿巾，帮她擦屁股。
Nobody's going to give me a shot today, are they?
今天没人要给我打针吧？
No, we have to take some blood, though. We have to go to the lab, and they're going to take some blood.
不，不过我们得抽点血。我们得去实验室，他们要抽点血。
Well, that's a shot.
好吧，那也是打针。
It's not a shot. They're drawing blood.
那不是打针。那是抽血。
They put--
他们把——
They stick you, but they're not giving you a shot. They're taking blood. There's a difference.
他们扎你，但不是给你打针。他们在抽血。这是有区别的。
You ever tried it?
你试过吗？
Margie's only 66, but in the last couple of years, she's had a heart attack and two small strokes, which paralyzed her right arm and affected her memory. It cuts in and out like faulty wiring. Sometimes she's talkative and remembers a lot. Sometimes she's not and she doesn't.
玛姬才66岁，但在过去几年里，她心脏病发作过一次，还中风了两次，这导致她右臂瘫痪，并影响了她的记忆力。记忆像接触不良的电线一样时断时续。有时她很健谈，记得很多事。有时则不然，什么都不记得。
Hey, you know what? Lift your breast for me again so that we can make sure. You don't have a rash under there anymore, do you?
嘿，你知道吗？再为我抬起乳房，这样我们好确认一下。你那里没起疹子了吧？
I don't think so.
我想没有了。
Because we've got to make sure it stays dry so it doesn't get a rash under there.
因为我们得确保它保持干燥，这样下面才不会起疹子。
Mubarak, is this closer than you ever thought you'd get to an adult woman's body?
穆巴拉克，这是不是你离一个成年女性的身体最近的一次？
[LAUGHS] You could say that.
[笑] 你可以这么说。
But this is the end of the story. This is today. Let's go back to the beginning. Mubarak's family didn't really notice that he was, as he tells it, a big sissy, because they were all oddballs. No matter where they were living, at least one of them was always not quite fitting in.
但这已是故事的结尾了。这是今天。让我们回到开头。穆巴拉克的家人并没有真正注意到他是一个，正如他所说的那样，大娘娘腔，因为他们都是怪人。无论他们住在哪里，他们中总至少有一个人不太合群。
Margie's from Georgia and lived most of her married life either up north or in the Middle East. Mubarak's father, Sabir, is Palestinian, born in Jordan. But for most of the marriage, they all lived in a small town in Pennsylvania where he was a professor of civil engineering. Now if Mubarak was a sissy in white, working-class, Catholic Hershey, PA, Sabir was too.
玛姬来自佐治亚州，大部分婚后生活要么在北方，要么在中东。穆巴拉克的父亲萨比尔是巴勒斯坦人，出生于约旦。但在大部分婚姻生活中，他们都住在宾夕法尼亚州的一个小镇，他是一名土木工程教授。如果说穆巴拉克在白人、工人阶级、天主教区的宾州赫尔希是个娘娘腔，那萨比尔也一样。
We got a week off of school every year because so many people, so many boys, went deer hunting. And of course, I didn't go hunting, and I didn't play football. And I didn't do all of those things that the boys in the neighborhood were supposed to do, especially hunting. Hunting was like a yardstick of when you reached manhood.
我们每年有一周的假期，因为很多人，很多男孩子，都去猎鹿了。当然，我没有去打猎，我也没有踢足球。我没有做那些邻里男孩应该做的所有事情，尤其是打猎。打猎就像衡量一个人是否成年的标准。
Sabir, meanwhile, to Mubarak's shame and horror, had to call on neighborhood dads to do simple mechanical tasks like unclogging a drain. And Margie was the one who hung their wedding pictures because Sabir claimed he didn't know how to hammer a nail.
与此同时，萨比尔，让穆巴拉克感到羞耻和恐惧的是，他不得不请邻居爸爸们来做些简单的机械活，比如疏通下水道。而挂结婚照的人是玛姬，因为萨比尔声称他不知道怎么钉钉子。
No, Sabir didn't do any of that stuff. Sabir was always very formal. He always had a sport jacket. I remember cutting grass was a big deal out there, like lawn care, how green and how even and how perfect was your yard. And I remember Sabir was in the yard cutting the grass. And he was cutting the grass, and he had a sport coat and a tie on, which is funny if you think about it.
不，萨比尔从来不做那些事。萨比尔总是非常正式。他总是穿着运动夹克。我记得在那儿修剪草坪是一件大事，比如草坪护理，你的草坪有多绿、多平、多完美。我记得萨比尔在院子里割草。他穿着运动外套和领带，如果仔细想想，这挺搞笑的。
Why would he do it?
他为什么会那样？
I think that came from the Middle East idea that if you are educated, that there's a certain position that you have in society and that you should always look and act a certain way.
我想那源于中东的一种观念，即如果你受过教育，你在社会中就处于特定的位置，你应该始终看起来并表现出某种样子。
You can see why, in this atmosphere, Sabir at one point panicked and made Margie sign Mubarak up for Little League. To toughen him up, he told her. But mostly, Margie says, Sabir worshipped Mubarak. He adored him.
你可以明白为什么在这种氛围下，萨比尔有一次惊慌失措，让玛姬给穆巴拉克报名参加小联盟。他说这是为了锻炼他。但玛姬说，萨比尔主要是崇拜穆巴拉克。他宠爱他。
Mubarak this and Mubarak that and Mubarak the other. Everything he talked about was Mubarak. After he found out Mubarak was gay, he hardly ever said-- wouldn't hardly even mention his name.
穆巴拉克这、穆巴拉克那，穆巴拉克别的什么。他谈论的一切都是穆巴拉克。在他发现穆巴拉克是同性恋之后，他几乎再也没有说过——几乎都不提他的名字。
Margie was the one who made the phone call to Mubarak after finding a bunch of gay adult cards in his room. He was 20 years old and staying with friends in Germany at the time, on his way to a semester in England.
是玛姬在穆巴拉克的房间里发现了一堆同性恋成人卡片后给他打的电话。那时他20岁，正和德国的朋友住在一起，准备去英国上学期。
And it was the middle of the night. I don't remember if we were exactly in bed. And the mother came down and said in German to my friend, there's a phone call from America, and it's an emergency for your American friend. So I was all nervous, and I went upstairs. And it was Margie, and she was crying. She was hysterical. I said, "Margie, what's wrong?" And she said, "You have to come home now."
那时是半夜。我不记得我们是否已经在床上了。我母亲下楼用德语对我的朋友说，有个来自美国的电话，是你美国朋友的急事。所以我很紧张，跑上楼去。那是玛姬，她在哭。她歇斯底里。我说：“玛姬，怎么了？”她说：“你现在必须回家。”
And I said, "Why? What's wrong?" And she just kept repeating, "You have to come home now." And I kept trying to get out of her what was wrong. So she finally said, "We found a good hospital in Tennessee that can cure you." And then I knew what was wrong. And of course I told her that I wasn't coming home until the end of the semester, and I would see her in January. And I think I hung up right away.
我说：“为什么？怎么了？”她只是不断重复，“你现在必须回家。”我一直试图从她口中问出到底出了什么事。最后她说：“我们在田纳西州找到了一家很好的医院，能治好你。”那时我就知道怎么回事了。当然，我告诉她直到学期结束我才会回家，我会在一月份见到她。我想我立刻就挂断了电话。
This was the beginning of their world starting to shift and become something else. Sabir blamed Margie for Mubarak being gay. Sabir, who never raised his voice before, would pound the table and say Mubarak was gay because he's a mama's boy.
这是他们世界开始转变并变成另一番模样的开始。萨比尔责怪玛姬导致穆巴拉克成为同性恋。以前从不提高嗓门的萨比尔，会重重地拍桌子说穆巴拉克是同性恋，因为他是“妈宝”。
I didn't think I'd married the same person at those times. He used to be jolly and gay and cheerful and tell jokes. I didn't know him anymore. I guess he didn't know me either.
我觉得那时候我嫁的人都不一样了。他以前总是快乐、风趣、开朗，还爱讲笑话。我不认识他了。我想他也不认识我了。
He was in such bad shape that he had taken off time from the university. I think he took a whole semester off from teaching at the university. He was so bad at one point, he would sit and stare into space and not respond to conversations and questions. And they had home health care-- an IV for him at home because he wouldn't eat.
他的状况非常糟糕，以至于他不得不从大学请假。我想他从大学教学工作中请了整整一个学期的假。他有一次状态非常差，会呆坐在那里望着虚空，对对话和问题毫无反应。他们有家庭医疗护理——在家给他挂静脉滴注，因为他不吃东西。
When Mubarak came home around Christmas, they all sat down at the kitchen table for a family meeting.
当穆巴拉克在圣诞节左右回家时，他们都在厨房餐桌旁坐下来开了一个家庭会议。
Margie didn't say hardly anything the whole time. And neither did I, actually. Sabir did most of the talking. Basically, he started with, you're our son and we love you, but this is wrong, and this is an illness. I've looked into it, and there are doctors who say that if you just try, if you get help, that you can change.
玛姬全程几乎什么也没说。其实我也没有。萨比尔说了大部分话。基本上，他开头说的是，你是我们的儿子，我们爱你，但这不对，这是一种疾病。我调查过了，有医生说如果你尝试一下，如果你寻求帮助，你是可以改变的。
Did he say the word "homosexual"?
他说过“同性恋”这个词吗？
Oh, god, no. He would never say that. He would say, "your condition" or "your problem" or "your situation." He would never say the word "gay" or "homosexual" ever, ever, ever. Even in the years after that, he never, ever said that word.
天哪，没有。他永远不会那样说。他会说，“你的状况”或“你的问题”或“你的处境”。他永远、永远、永远不会说“同性恋”这个词。甚至在那之后的几年里，他也从来没有说过那个词。
The biggest problem with Mubarak being gay was that he would never have children. He would never have a son to carry on the family name as Sabir had done and as Sabir's father had done. This was Mubarak's obligation. After a long argument, the last thing Sabir said to Mubarak was this.
穆巴拉克是同性恋带来的最大问题是，他永远不会有孩子。他永远不会有儿子来继承家业，就像萨比尔所做的那样，也像萨比尔的父亲所做的那样。这是穆巴拉克的义务。经过一番激烈的争论，萨比尔对穆巴拉克说的最后一句话是这个。
I remember he looked at me and he said, "I will sell all the land in Palestine to raise the money to send you to a doctor if you ever decide that you would go." Being Palestinian and understanding how important land is, I mean, land is identity, it's a future, it's the past, it's everything. And for Sabir to say that he would sell all of his land showed that this was really the top priority in his whole life.
我记得他看着我说：“只要你决定去看医生，我会卖掉巴勒斯坦所有的土地来筹钱。”作为巴勒斯坦人，了解土地有多重要——我的意思是，土地就是身份，是未来，是过去，是一切。萨比尔说他会卖掉他所有的土地，这表明这确实是他一生中最重要的优先级。
For two years, nothing changed. Mubarak stayed in school and kept being gay. Sabir stayed depressed and wrote Mubarak long letters saying he loved Mubarak but Mubarak was sick and he owed it to Sabir to get help. Margie quietly began flooding Mubarak's college mailbox with condoms.
两年来，一切都没有改变。穆巴拉克继续上学，也继续做同性恋。萨比尔一直很抑郁，给穆巴拉克写长信，说他爱穆巴拉克，但穆巴拉克病了，他欠萨比尔一个去看病的机会。玛姬则悄悄开始往穆巴拉克的大学邮箱里塞避孕套。
Then Margie and Sabir moved back to the Middle East as they'd always planned to do when Sabir retired. He was 65. She was 59. Six months later, everything shifted again. The family mutated again, becoming more like what it would soon be and less like it had been before. It started with another phone call to Mubarak.
后来玛姬和萨比尔搬回了中东，正如他们一直计划在萨比尔退休后所做的那样。他65岁。她59岁。六个月后，一切又变了。这个家庭再次突变，变得越来越像它即将成为的样子，而不像它过去的样子。一切始于给穆巴拉克的另一个电话。
Well, the way I first found out about it was I got a telephone call one afternoon from Margie. She said, "Honey, do you think I could come live with you?" And I didn't know what she was talking about. I said, "Margie, what are you talking about?" She said, "Do you think I could come live with you?" And then she told me that she and Sabir were getting divorced because he was going to marry another woman and have another son.
好吧，我第一次发现这件事是因为那天下午我接到了玛姬的电话。她说：“亲爱的，你觉得我可以去和你住吗？”我不知道她在说什么。我说：“玛姬，你在说什么？”她说：“你觉得我可以去和你住吗？”然后她告诉我，她和萨比尔正在离婚，因为他打算娶另一个女人并再生一个儿子。
In fact, divorce wasn't even what Sabir wanted. At first, he asked Margie if she would be his partner in what he called--
事实上，离婚甚至不是萨比尔想要的。起初，他问玛姬是否愿意成为他的合伙人，他称之为——
Joint venture. I want you to help me find a young lady you think you can get along with. I said, "What?"
合资企业。我希望你帮我找一个你认为相处得来的年轻女士。我说：“什么？”
And he said, "I want to marry another woman and have a baby."
他说：“我想娶另一个女人并生个孩子。”
I said, "OK, Sabir, you better find one you think you can get along with because I'm not going to be here."
我说：“好吧，萨比尔，你最好找一个你认为相处得来的，因为我不会留在这里。”
And that was plan A, and the plan B was having another wife at a different apartment. And then plan C was him getting married in the West Bank, just going down there a couple weeks a year, and then basically living with Margie in Jordan. And her response to that was always my favorite. That's when she asked him-- she said, "OK, that's fine as long as I can have a--
那是A计划，B计划是在另一套公寓里再养一个妻子。C计划是在西岸结婚，每年去那里住几个星期，然后基本上和玛姬一起住在约旦。她对此的回应一直是我最喜欢的。那时候她问他——她说：“好吧，那没问题，只要我能有个——
Boyfriend. He said, "Why?" And I said, "So when you ask me what I've been doing, I'll tell you the same thing you've been doing while you were over there." He didn't appreciate that either.
男朋友。他说：“为什么？”我说：“这样当你问我在做什么时，我会告诉你，你在那边时做的事情，我也做了。”他对此也不欣赏。
And I remember Sabir wrote me a very, very long letter explaining what he was doing and why he was doing it and how he had been forced into doing this because for years he had been asking me to go get help, and I was just ignoring him. And he felt that since I was not going to have a son to carry on the family name, that the responsibility of making sure that the family name survived suddenly became his again. And this was the only way he could see to do it. And he was very heavy on the, "This is your fault. You're doing this to Margie, not me."
我记得萨比尔给我写了一封非常、非常长的信，解释他在做什么、为什么要这样做，以及他是如何被迫这样做的。因为多年来他一直要求我去寻求帮助，而我却一直在无视他。他觉得既然我不会有儿子来继承家业，那么确保家族名声延续下去的责任突然又变回了他的。他认为这是他唯一能看到的办法。他在信里非常强调，“这是你的错。是你把这事强加给玛姬的，不是我。”
The other thing that was really strange was he spent pages saying, "Your mother is being very close-minded about all of this. Try to help me convince her to stay here. She doesn't have to leave. I don't want her to leave."
另一件非常奇怪的事是，他花了好几页纸说，“你母亲对这一切非常闭塞。试着帮我劝劝她留下来。她不必离开。我不想让她离开。”
So Sabir divorced Margie, telling her every day until she left that he loved her and didn't want her to leave. And she got on the plane and began the life she's pretty much living now. From that point on, instead of a husband, she would have a son. And from the moment the plane touched down, he treated her the way you'd want your husband to treat you.
于是萨比尔和玛姬离了婚，在玛姬离开前每天都告诉她他爱她，不想让她走。她登上了飞机，开始了她现在所过的生活。从那时起，她没有了丈夫，却有了一个儿子。从飞机着陆的那一刻起，他就以你希望丈夫对待你的方式对待她。
I'll never forget when I came back, getting off plane. We got through customs and all that stuff. I saw this great big bunch of flowers somebody was holding way up in the air. Beautiful, beautiful bunch of flowers. And I said, somebody is certainly going to get themselves a beautiful bouquet of flowers. And guess who that was.
我永远不会忘记我回来下飞机的时候。我们办完了海关手续之类的。我看到有人高高举起一大束花。非常非常漂亮的花束。我说，肯定有人要收到一束美丽的花了。猜猜那个人是谁。
Well, any guesses? Margie moved into Mubarak's graduate school apartment, which, by the way, was at the same university where Sabir had taught. In her old life, she'd been supported by one man, her husband, the professor. In her new life, she was surrounded by a whole sissy entourage. Mubarak's friends were always coming in and whisking her away to the orchestra, to plays. They adored her.
好吧，有什么猜测吗？玛姬搬进了穆巴拉克的读研公寓，顺便说一句，那正是萨比尔以前教书的大学。在她的旧生活中，她由一个男人，她的丈夫，那位教授供养。在新生活中，她被一群娘娘腔包围着。穆巴拉克的那些朋友总是过来把她带去听交响乐、看戏。他们非常宠爱她。
She still cried every day, many times a day, for the first few months. And every day, she got at least one letter from Sabir, sometimes two. Finally one day, the letter that came from Sabir said he'd gotten married. Mubarak, not knowing what was in the letter, gave it to Margie and went to his room.
头几个月，她仍然每天哭，一天哭很多次。每天她至少能收到一封萨比尔的信，有时是两封。终于有一天，萨比尔寄来的信里说他结婚了。穆巴拉克不知道信里写了什么，就把它给了玛姬，然后回自己房间了。
We came back out. It was five or 10 minutes later. And she was still sitting there, but she had a funny look on her face. So I said, "Are you OK?" And she started saying things like, "Please don't hurt me, please don't hurt me" and crying. I'm like, "Margie, what are you talking about?"
我们五十分钟或十分钟后回来。她还坐在那儿，但脸上的表情很奇怪。我说：“你还好吗？”她开始说些诸如“请别伤害我，请别伤害我”之类的话，并哭了起来。我心想，“玛姬，你在说什么？”
"Don't come any closer. Don't come any closer. Don't hurt me." And she didn't know who I was. She didn't know who she was.
“别再靠近我。别再靠近我。别伤害我。”她不知道我是谁。她不知道她自己是谁。
I was just out of it.
我当时简直失控了。
Her amnesia-- Mubarak calls it a vacation from the bad news-- lasted several days.
她的健忘症——穆巴拉克称之为“坏消息的假期”——持续了几天。
One, two, three.
一，二，三。
There you go.
这就对了。
We're in Margie's cardiologist's office, and she's about to surprise me. On the last day I spend with Margie and Mubarak, she suddenly murmurs that she wishes Mubarak had gotten married.
我们在玛姬的心脏病医生办公室，她正准备给我一个惊喜。在我陪玛姬和穆巴拉克度过的最后一天，她突然嘀咕说她希望穆巴拉克能结婚。
I wish you would've married.
我希望你能结婚。
You wish that Mubarak would've married?
你希望穆巴拉克结婚？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Who?
和谁？
Mark Stoner.
马克·斯托纳。
Now most mothers who say, oh, I wish my gay son had gotten married, and you ask them who, they don't say a man.
现在，大多数说“哦，我希望我同性恋儿子能结婚”的母亲，当你问她们和谁时，她们不会说一个男人。
Mark Stoner.
马克·斯托纳。
So you don't wish Mubarak had married any girl that you know?
所以你不希望穆巴拉克和你认识的任何女孩结婚？
I wish he'd married Mark Stoner, because he was a nice guy and he loved Mubarak a lot.
我希望他能和马克·斯托纳结婚，因为他是个好人，而且他非常爱穆巴拉克。
Even after all the time I'd spent with her, I had completely expected her to say a woman's name. Because even though it's common when men come out as gay for their mothers to be more accepting than their fathers, there are usually at least some pretty clear limits for the mothers too, certain ways that they're used to seeing the world and just can't give up.
即使在我和她相处了这么久之后，我还是完全预料到她会说一个女人的名字。因为尽管男人出柜成为同性恋时，母亲比父亲更接受是常见的，但母亲们通常也有一些非常明确的底线，一些她们习惯看世界的方式，只是无法放弃。
But Margie's world and Mubarak's are not really separate as they are for most gay people and their parents. Mubarak is really glad she's here. He says it all the time. And he spends a lot of time with Margie, willingly, happily. He's the only person I know who seems as unambivalent in his love for his mother as she is in her love for him. Every once in a while, he talks about something I know he thinks about a lot, which is that this is the end of Margie's life, and he's grateful that she's spending it here where he can be with her.
但玛姬和穆巴拉克的世界并不像大多数同性恋及其父母那样是分开的。穆巴拉克很高兴她在这里。他总是这么说。他花很多时间陪伴玛姬，心甘情愿，乐在其中。他是唯一一个我认识的人，似乎对自己母亲的爱像母亲对他那样坚定不移。偶尔，他会谈论一些我知道他经常思考的事情，那就是这是玛姬生命的尽头，他很感激她能在这里度过这段时光，这样他就能陪着她。
OK. Margie? Are you OK?
好吧。玛姬？你还好吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
You're wobbling back and forth. Margie? Margie? Margie, talk to me.
你摇摇晃晃的。玛姬？玛姬？玛姬，跟我说说话。
What is it, Barkie?
怎么了，巴基？
What's happening?
发生什么事了？
While I was taping, Margie had what seemed to be a small stroke.
在我录音的时候，玛姬似乎轻微中风了。
Margie? Margie? Margie?
玛姬？玛姬？玛姬？
Do you want me to call 911, Mubarak?
穆巴拉克，你要我打911吗？
It all happened in about two minutes. And when it was over, Margie seemed fine, although disoriented and tired. She couldn't really remember what had happened. We were more shaken than she was. Mubarak and I talked in the kitchen afterward while he made Margie some tea.
这一切发生在两分钟之内。结束后，玛姬看起来没问题，虽然有点神志不清和疲惫。她不太记得发生了什么事。我们比她更惊慌。事后，当他给玛姬泡茶时，穆巴拉克和我在厨房聊了聊。
That was really scary.
那太吓人了。
That was so frightening. Because it's so scary when you go to the hospital-- I remember the first time I went. And she had congestive heart failure, and you don't know what that means. You hear "heart failure," and you panic. And then I remember the other two times, going into the hospital and thinking, it should be easier this time. But every time it happens, it gets scarier because you think you're one step closer to something really awful happening. I'm going to be a mess whenever anything really serious happens.
那真是太可怕了。因为去医院太吓人了——我记得我第一次去的时候。她心力衰竭，你不知道那意味着什么。你听到“心力衰竭”，你就慌了。然后我记得另外两次，去医院时心想，这次应该容易些。但每次发生时，都变得更可怕，因为你觉得你离某些真正糟糕的事情发生又近了一步。每次发生任何真正严重的事情，我都会崩溃的。
We just did that because we knew you were going to be tape recording today. I'm like, "Margie, do think think you can have a little heart failure this afternoon?" [LAUGHS]
我们刚才那么做只是因为我们知道你今天要录音。我心想，“玛姬，你觉得你今天下午能稍微心力衰竭一下吗？”[笑]
Just do what you can.
尽力而为就行。
I'm so scared all the time.
我一直都很害怕。
P.S., it might not be clear from this story, but I think Margie really loved Sabir. I think he really loved her. We saw it clear as day in the pages of her wedding scrapbook. She turns to a picture from her wedding day. Sabir's embracing Margie, and both their eyes are closed. They're smiling. They look completely happy, probably not even aware the picture's being taken.
注：这个故事可能没讲清楚，但我认为玛姬是真的爱萨比尔。我认为他也真的很爱她。我们在她的结婚相册里看得一清二楚。她翻到婚礼当天的一张照片。萨比尔拥抱着玛姬，两人都闭着眼睛。他们微笑着。他们看起来完全幸福，可能甚至没意识到照片正在被拍摄。
What were you thinking right at that moment when that was happening?
那时候你心里在想什么？
I got that man. He's mine now. [LAUGHS] My mother had told me, when you find the right one, you know it. And I did. Well, I thought he was the right one. Turned out he wasn't. I never did find the right one.
我得到了那个男人。他现在是我的了。[笑] 我母亲告诉过我，当你找到对的那个人，你会知道的。我找到了。嗯，我以为他是对的人。结果他不是。我从来没有找到过对的人。
[MUSIC - "I'M IN SUCH PAIN FROM LOVING YOU" BY LINDA RONSTADT, DOLLY PARTON, AND EMMYLOU HARRIS]
[音乐 - 琳达·朗丝黛、多莉·帕顿和埃米卢·哈里斯演唱的《我因爱你而痛苦》]
Act Two, Instructions For Sissies.
第二幕，娘娘腔指南。
I'm joined here in the studio right now by John Connors, who often provides music for our program and also performs around Chicago. And you've brought in a book with you. The name of the book is?
我现在在演播室，与我在一起的是约翰·康纳斯，他经常为我们的节目提供音乐，也经常在芝加哥各地表演。你带了一本书来。书名是？
How to Improve Your Personality.
《如何提升你的个性》。
It's written in huge block letters on the cover.
封面上有巨大的块状字母。
Well, it's a black cover with white and sort of this-- would you call it a daisy yellow?
嗯，那是黑色的封面，配着白色和那种——你会称它为雏菊黄吗？
Yes.
是的。
A daisy yellow.
雏菊黄。
I would.
我会的。
And it was funny because walking down Lincoln Avenue, it's really funny how people sort of look at you in this odd way when you're carrying a book on how to improve your personality. Immediately, you're suspect, and they wonder what's wrong. And then I, of course, turn the book so no one can read it. So I'm thinking, I'm so insecure with my personality that I don't want people to think that there's something wrong.
这很有趣，因为走在林肯大道上，很有意思的是，当你带着一本关于如何提升个性的书时，人们看你的眼神总是怪怪的。你会立刻受到怀疑，他们会想你有什么问题。当然，我随后会把书转过来，让别人读不到。所以我心想，我对自己的个性太不自信了，以至于我不想让人们认为有什么问题。
And this book has an important lesson for us-- for our program today, on our theme today. And why don't you just open it up and read?
这本书对我们有一个重要的教训——为我们今天的节目，关于我们今天的主题。你为什么不把它翻开读一读呢？
This is from the chapter "Good Appearance: Grooming" from the section "Other Appearance Factors in Men."
这是出自“良好外表：仪容”章节，摘自“男性其他外表因素”部分。
Copyright?
版权？
Copyright 1942. Reprint, 1954.
版权1942年。重印1954年。
"If your physique, complexion, voice, speech, habits, carriage, or general behavior in the slightest degree suggest a femininity, do everything in your power to create an impression of masculinity. Pitch your voice lower. Develop your arm muscles and your chest expansion. Avoid pet expressions and exclamations commonly used by women.
“如果你的体格、肤色、嗓音、言谈、习惯、仪态或总体行为有丝毫女性化的暗示，就要尽一切努力创造一种男性化的印象。把嗓音调低。锻炼手臂肌肉和胸廓。避免使用女性常用的口头禅和感叹词。
See that your posture and walk are masculine. Hold up your shoulders. Throw out your chest. Take longer steps. Think masculine and act masculine. Here's a list of gestures commonly associated with women and another list commonly associated with men. If you use any of the feminine gestures, stop at once and substitute the corresponding masculine gesture. You'll have to watch yourself pretty closely on this one.
注意你的姿势和走路方式要男性化。挺起双肩。挺起胸膛。迈大步。男性化地思考，男性化地行动。这是一份女性常见的姿势列表，以及另一份男性常见的姿势列表。如果你使用了任何女性化的姿势，请立即停止并代之以相应的男性化姿势。在这方面你得密切注意自己。
Feminine gesture, hand on hip. Masculine gesture, hands folded over chest or clasped in back. Feminine gesture, tapping front teeth with fingernail. Masculine gesture, clenched fist under chin or jaw. Feminine gesture, looking at people from the corner of eyes. Masculine gesture, direct look. Entire head turned toward person. Feminine gesture, putting one hand up to the back to touch hair. Masculine gesture, clenching fingers of both hands together firmly at the back of head.
女性姿势，手叉腰。男性姿势，双手交叉叠在胸前或背后。女性姿势，用手指敲前牙。男性姿势，下巴或颌下握拳。女性姿势，用眼角看人。男性姿势，直视。头要整个转向对方。女性姿势，一只手抬起去摸后脑勺的头发。男性姿势，双手手指紧握在后脑勺。
How do you laugh? Are your laughs pitched high like a woman's? [HIGH-PITCHED LAUGH] Lower the pitch. Develop a masculine laugh. Chuckle. Laugh from the depths of your chest and stomach. [DEEPER LAUGH] Roar. Bellow. Do anything but giggle. Don't be guilty of a high, hysterical laugh. Listen to Edward Arnold and Clark Gable in the movies. Imitate their laughter. You can't do it, but you can at least try."
你怎么笑？你的笑声像女人一样尖吗？[尖细的笑声] 把音调降低。培养一种男性化的笑声。低笑。从胸腔和腹部深处发出笑声。[深沉的笑声] 咆哮。大吼。做什么都行，就是别咯咯笑。不要发出尖锐、歇斯底里的笑声。多听电影里的爱德华·阿诺德和克拉克·盖博。模仿他们的笑声。你可能做不到，但至少可以试一试。”
Hey, John?
嘿，约翰？
Hmm?
嗯？
Can you imagine a gay man in 1942 actually reading this and trying to follow these instructions?
你能想象1942年的一个同性恋男人真的读了这本书并试图遵循这些指示吗？
Yeah, of course.
是的，当然。
You can?
你真的能？
I mean, I could see people taking notes. Self-help books are still the same.
我的意思是，我能看到人们在做笔记。自我提升类书籍永远都是这样。
OK, but when you picture this guy in 1942 reading this book, this effeminate guy reading the book and thinking, "OK, OK, I've got to do that," where is he, and who is he?
好吧，但当你脑海中浮现出1942年这个读这本书的家伙，这个读着这本书心想“好的，好的，我必须这么做”的女性化男人时，他在哪里，他是谁？
Well, he's probably still living at home. Probably the unmarried 30-year-old who his last ditch effort is to prove to everyone that he's not the sissy that everyone thinks he is and that there must be a formula for it.
嗯，他可能还住在家里。可能就是那个30岁还没结婚的人，他最后孤注一掷地努力向所有人证明他不是大家认为的那个娘娘腔，而且证明一定有一个公式可以做到。
I picture this guy-- let's call him Benton-- and he's in his bedroom at his parents' house, and he has remodeled since he was a kid. And it's 1942. Is he 4-F? Is he going to go to the war? Has he been to the war?
我脑海中浮现出这个家伙——我们叫他本顿——他在父母家的卧室里，自从小时候起就没怎么重新装修过。那是1942年。他是4-F级吗？他要参军吗？他去过战场吗？
If you're putting the war factor into this, maybe you have somebody who's in their early 20s who can't get into the war because he is so effeminate. I've seen documentaries of gay men in World War II, and I think there probably came a point when, actually, they had to take pretty much everybody.
如果你把战争因素考虑进去，也许你有一个20出头的人，因为他太女性化而进不了军队。我看过二战时期的同性恋纪录片，我想可能到了某个时候，他们实际上不得不几乎征召所有人。
And there were the famous gay battalions--
还有著名的同性恋营——
Exactly.
正是。
--that went into France first because they were the only ones that could speak French.
——他们是第一批进入法国的，因为他们是唯一会说法语的人。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
"Send in the gay battalion!"
“派同性恋营上去！”
And raided the lingerie shops and redesigned all the clothes. Just redecorated the whole place so the Germans didn't want it anymore because it was just too foofy for them. "We won't be staying here. It's far too foofy." Oh, god.
然后他们抢劫了内衣店，重新设计了所有的衣服。只是重新装饰了整个地方，这样德国人就不想在那儿待了，因为它对他们来说太花哨了。“我们不会留在这里。这太花哨了。”哦，天哪。
Well, John Connors. Coming up, more sissies in the house. Dan Savage, many people without clenched fists under their jaw. That's all in a minute when our program continues.
好了，约翰·康纳斯。接下来，还有更多的“室内娘娘腔”。丹·萨维奇，许多下颌下没有紧握拳头的人。这一切将在我们节目继续后的那一分钟里揭晓。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you documentaries, monologues, overheard conversations, found tape, found text, anything we can think of on that theme. Today's program, Sissies. We've arrived at Act Three of our program, The Pansy Kings Sing Songs of Love. And we've arrived at this question. Why do sissies freak people out so much? What is the big deal, anyway?
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来纪录片、独白、无意中听到的对话、找到的磁带、找到的文字，任何我们能想到的关于那个主题的内容。今天的节目主题：娘娘腔。我们已经到了节目的第三幕，《三色堇之王唱响爱之歌》。我们已经到了这个问题：为什么娘娘腔让人如此抓狂？到底有什么大不了的？
I would argue that there are two things going on with sissies. First of all, there's the idea that they're weak, right? And since everybody has, at one point or another in their life, feared being seen as weak, it can be painful to see somebody else who seems weak. Second, there's the fact that they cross gender lines, sissies do. These are boys who  act like girls, or that's the stereotype, anyway.
我会争辩说娘娘腔身上发生着两件事。首先，大家认为他们软弱，对吧？既然每个人在生命中的某个时刻都曾害怕被视为软弱，看到别人表现出软弱可能会让人痛苦。其次，事实是娘娘腔跨越了性别界限。这些是表现得像女孩的男孩，或者至少这是刻板印象。
This next story is about a sissy who got rid of half of that formula. He got rid of the appearing weak part of it. And by doing that, he was able to get away with crossing gender lines and acting more androgynous. This is the story of Dave Awl, a man who these days embraces his sissiness.
接下来的这个故事是关于一个摆脱了这个公式一半内容的娘娘腔。他摆脱了显得软弱的那部分。通过这样做，他能够跨越性别界限，表现得更加中性。这是戴夫·奥尔的故事，一个在今天拥抱自己“娘娘腔”特质的男人。
"Embraces" isn't even big enough for his relationship to his sissiness. He's a guy who founded something called The Pansy Kings, gay and sissy performers who do a show they call the Pansy King Cotillion here in Chicago. But back in Peoria where he grew up, he was not so happy being a sissy.
“拥抱”甚至不足以形容他与自己“娘娘腔”特质的关系。他创立了一个叫“三色堇之王”的组织，由同性恋和娘娘腔表演者组成，他们在芝加哥表演一场名为“三色堇之王舞会”的秀。但在他长大的皮奥里亚，他并不那么喜欢做娘娘腔。
I got my leg broken in PE class for wrestling. Instead of matching people with people who were of their same strength, they would match you with a guy who was of your same weight. Well, of course, I was this really fat kid-- really, really heavy, overweight kid. And the other guy, who weighed the same of me, was a sheet of beef. He was this big, simian, hulk of a guy.
我的腿在体育课摔跤时断了。他们没有把力量相当的人配对，而是把体重相当的人配对。嗯，当然，我是个非常胖的孩子——非常、非常重，超重的孩子。而另一个和我体重一样的人，是一块大肉块。他是一个巨大的、像猿猴一样的壮汉。
And the PE teacher, perhaps out of cluelessness but also, I think, there was some malice toward the pansy kid and wanting to see the pansy kid get messed over, he has me wrestle the brute. So it's me and the brute out there on the mat.
体育老师，也许是因为无知，但也因为我认为他们对那个“娘娘腔”孩子心怀恶意，想看他吃苦头，于是让我和那个粗人摔跤。所以我和那个粗人在垫子上。
And of course, within 30 seconds, I'm lying on the mat, and my leg is in two pieces. And I just remember that I was sort of moaning and crying, "Oh dear, oh dear. Oh my, oh my." Which had to be probably the most Blanche DuBois-like moment of my young life as I was carried out on the stretcher crying, "Oh dear, oh my. Oh my, oh dear."
当然，30秒内，我就躺在垫子上，腿断成两截了。我只记得我一边呻吟一边哭着，“噢天哪，噢天哪。噢，我的天啊。”这大概是我年轻时最像布兰奇·杜波依斯的时刻，我被抬上担架，哭着喊：“噢天哪，噢我的天。噢我的天，噢天哪。”
I got a lot of abuse, especially in PE class because I was bad at sports. And obviously that was important to the other kids, and they didn't want to have me on their team. I got a lot of insults in the hallway or people knocking my books out of my hands or whatever. And what happened is I started to develop a persona.
我遭受了很多虐待，特别是在体育课上，因为我不擅长运动。显然这对其他孩子很重要，他们不想让我加入他们的队伍。我在走廊里受了很多侮辱，或者有人把我的书从我手里打掉之类的。后来发生的事情是，我开始培养一种人格。
And my best friend at that time was a girl who went to another high school, named Lydia. And she was very punk. She was the punk rock girl. And what I did is, naturally, I started changing my look. And I got the very first spiky punk haircut ever seen in East Peoria. And the effect that this had was really strange, because I went from being overtly and aggressively mocked to being really given a wide berth. I went from being mocked to almost being feared, because suddenly, I was turning up at school with this weird spiky haircut, wearing these baggy yellow trousers a la Madness and vintage green suit jackets.
我当时最好的朋友是一个在另一所高中上学的女孩，叫莉迪亚。她非常朋克。她是那个朋克摇滚女孩。于是我自然而然地开始改变我的造型。我在东皮奥里亚剪了第一个从未见过的尖尖的朋克发型。这产生的影响非常奇怪，因为我从一个被公开、被强力嘲笑的对象，变成了真的被大家保持距离。我从被嘲笑变成了几乎被畏惧，因为我突然以这种奇怪的尖头发、穿着这种类似Madness乐队的肥大黄色长裤和复古绿色西装外套出现在学校。
And you've got to understand that at my high school, to walk down the hallways, it looked like a Loverboy video. There was this very specific uniform that consisted of a really ugly flannel shirt, a black t-shirt under it that could say one of five things, and only these five things-- Led Zeppelin, AC/DC, REO Speedwagon, Jack Daniels, or Harley-Davidson. And you could not deviate from that palette.
你必须明白，在我的高中，走在走廊里，看起来就像《Loverboy》的录像带一样。有一种非常特定的制服，由一件非常难看的法兰绒衬衫，里面配一件只能写这五种东西之一的黑色T恤组成——Led Zeppelin, AC/DC, REO Speedwagon, Jack Daniels, 或 Harley-Davidson。你不能偏离这个调色板。
So I turn up dressed like a refugee from a Madness video or a David Bowie album cover. And to them, to come to school looking like that, I must be capable of anything. I had a friend tell me he had overheard these two senior burnout girls talking, and one of them said something like, "That Dave Awl, he's crazy. He'd jump in front of a bus if you told him to. He looks like he could kill somebody."
所以我打扮得像Madness录像带里的难民或大卫·鲍伊专辑封面的难民出现在学校。对他们来说，这样来学校，我一定什么都干得出来。一个朋友告诉我，他无意中听到两个高三的颓废派女生谈话，其中一个说类似这样的话，“那个戴夫·奥尔，他疯了。如果你告诉他，他会跳到公交车前。他看起来像是会杀人的人。”
There was nothing further from the truth. I was probably the only kid in that school who would never have taken a pill my mother didn't give me. And frankly, I was awfully cowed by authority. But suddenly, I had this look.
没有比这更离谱的事实了。我大概是学校里唯一一个绝不会吃我母亲没给我的药的孩子。坦白说，我对权威非常畏惧。但突然间，我有了这种外表。
You were still a sissy.
你仍然是一个娘娘腔。
Uh huh. I was still a sissy, but I was a different kind of sissy, because what the punk new wave aesthetic allowed you to do was be androgynous in a way that was also kind of tough. You had this dyed, funny hair, but you also had a safety pin through your ear. And you were maybe wearing eyeliner, but you were also wearing ripped jeans and a black biker jacket. So what it did is it confused them because it was sending all of these mixed signals.
嗯哼。我仍然是一个娘娘腔，但我是一个不同类型的娘娘腔，因为朋克新浪潮美学允许你以一种既有点强硬又中性的方式存在。你染了滑稽的头发，但你的耳朵上也别着别针。你可能涂着眼线，但你也穿着破洞牛仔裤和黑色摩托夹克。所以它迷惑了他们，因为它发出了所有这些混合的信号。
A signal of violence at the same time as a signal of something else.
暴力信号的同时又发出了某种其他信号。
Well, at least a signal of, don't mess with me. I can take care of myself, and I'm not afraid of you. I call it the "squid strategy." You muddy the waters as an act of defense. You shoot out a lot of ink into the water and confuse them, and suddenly they don't know where to strike. Because suddenly, they didn't think I looked like what they meant by a faggot anymore, which is someone who's really pathetic and weak, because I also looked kind of tough and strange. And yet, there were these androgynous elements. And the result is that they just started leaving me alone. I didn't get called a faggot anymore in the hallway. I didn't really get called anything. And what I discovered was that while I would never have chosen to be feared on my own, once there, I realized that it was a lot better than being mocked.
嗯，至少是一个“别惹我”的信号。我可以照顾自己，我不怕你。我称之为“乌贼策略”。你作为一种防御手段搅浑水。你向水中喷射大量墨汁来迷惑他们，突然他们就不知道从哪里下手了。因为突然间，他们觉得我看起来不再像他们所说的“死基佬”了，即那种非常可怜和软弱的人，因为我也看起来有点强硬和奇怪。然而，这里面又有那些中性元素。结果是他们开始不理我了。我再也没在走廊里被称为“死基佬”。我真的没被叫什么。我发现的是，虽然我绝不会选择被畏惧，但一旦真的被畏惧，我意识到这比被嘲笑好多了。
The problem is I was still not dealing with the internalized sissy phobia, because I was allowed to be androgynous. I was allowed to wear makeup or wear earrings or wear big flowery paisley shirts, only to the extent that I had this cover of also having the safety pin in the ear or the ripped jeans or the spiky hair or whatever looked tough. And it wasn't until college or a little after that I realized the real challenge was to be able to simply go out there like a drag queen does, without any of those balancing affectations of masculinity or toughness. To really be a sissy and go out there only using the persona elements that are considered to be feminine was something I was still very afraid to do.
问题是我仍然没有处理好内在的对“娘娘腔”的恐惧，因为我被允许表现得中性。我被允许化妆或戴耳环，或穿大花纹佩斯利衬衫，仅限于我有别针在耳朵上或破洞牛仔裤或尖发型这些看起来强硬的保护色。直到大学或之后，我才意识到真正的挑战是能够简单地像变装皇后那样走出去，而不带任何那些为了平衡而作出的男性化或强硬的姿态。真正成为一个娘娘腔，只使用那些被认为是女性化的人格元素，这是我仍然非常害怕做的事情。
It's interesting that you were able to accept the fact that you were gay long before you were able to accept the fact that you were a sissy.
有趣的是，你在接受自己是同性恋之前很久，就已经能够接受自己是娘娘腔的事实了。
I think that's really telling about which prejudice is more deeply rooted. I think a lot of homophobia comes from its association with sissiness, because the sissiness-- the breaking of those sacred gender categories-- is the deeper phobia in our culture.
我认为这真的说明了哪种偏见更根深蒂固。我认为很多恐同心理来自于它与“娘娘腔”的关联，因为娘娘腔——对那些神圣性别分类的打破——是我们文化中更深层的恐惧。
It would be much easier for me to walk down the street carrying a copy of The Joy of Gay Sex openly than it would be to walk down the street in a pair of sparkly, ruby red high heels in this city, in this urban environment. I think I'm capable of doing both. But which one would I feel a little bit more inner self-consciousness or anxiety about doing? It would be breaking the sissy barrier.
比起在城市环境中穿着一双亮晶晶的红宝石色高跟鞋走在街上，公开携带一本《同性性爱之乐》走在街上对我来说要容易得多。我想我都有能力做这两件事。但哪一件会让我感到更多的内在自我意识或焦虑？那将是打破娘娘腔的界限。
Dave Awl is the founder of the Pansy Kings performance collective and the host of The Partly Dave Show , a cabaret variety show here in Chicago.
戴夫·奥尔是“三色堇之王”表演团的创始人，也是芝加哥卡巴莱综艺节目《戴夫秀》的主持人。
[MUSIC - "GIRL'S BIKE" BY THE ALUMINUM GROUP]
[音乐 - 铝乐队的《女孩的自行车》]
Act Four, The Other Love that Dare Not Speak its Name. The love that we're talking about in this act is the love of sissies. Dan Savage is a writer and editor at The Stranger, a weekly paper in Seattle, and author of the syndicated sex advice column, "Savage Love." Dan Savage says that he's met hundreds of gay men. Thousands. Enough that he can state definitively that most of them do not act like sissies, which he says is a shame for him because he loves sissies.
第四幕，另一个不敢说出口的爱。我们在这一幕中谈论的爱是娘娘腔之爱。丹·萨维奇是西雅图周报《Stranger》的编辑和作家，也是联合辛迪加性建议专栏“萨维奇之爱”的作者。丹·萨维奇说他见过成百上千的同性恋男人。数以千计。足以让他明确地断言，他们中的大多数行为并不像娘娘腔，他说这对他来说很遗憾，因为他爱娘娘腔。
My boyfriend is kind of a sissy. He hates it when I mention it, and when he finds out that I said it on National Public Radio, he's going to kill me. But he is kind of a sissy. He cooks. He likes to do laundry. He's into fashion and Brit pop and Barbra Streisand. And all that's OK with me. I hate to cook. And if he wants to listen to Funny Girl while he folds my shirts, well, I can deal.
我的男朋友有点娘娘腔。他讨厌我提到这件事，当他发现我在国家公共广播电台说了这件事时，他会杀了我。但他确实有点娘娘腔。他会做饭。他喜欢洗衣服。他热衷于时尚、英伦摇滚和芭芭拉·史翠珊。这一切我都能接受。我讨厌做饭。如果他想在叠我衬衫时听《妙女郎》，好吧，我应付得来。
And besides, it's really no sacrifice on my part. I think sissies are sexy. Though sissy isn't the right word, really. Little boys who play with dolls are sissies. Grown men who went to see The Mirror Has Two Faces on the morning it opened and loved it are known in gay slang, at least, as femmes.
况且，对我来说这根本不算牺牲。我觉得娘娘腔很性感。虽然“娘娘腔”这个词其实不太对。玩娃娃的小男孩是娘娘腔。早上刚上映就去看《双面镜》并爱上它的成年男人，在同性恋俚语中至少被称为“femmes”（女性化男同志）。
My attraction to femmy guys is rooted, I have no doubt, in a high school experience. At St. Gregory the Great where I spent my sophomore year, there was this senior-- totally femmy and gay and out of the closet-- and this was in 1979. He dressed in Kmart disco fashions and wore his hair long and used eyeliner.
我对女性化男人的吸引力，毫无疑问植根于高中的经历。在圣格雷戈里大中学，我度过了高二那年，有个高三学生——完全女性化，同性恋，公开出柜——那时是1979年。他穿着凯马特折扣店的迪斯科服装，留着长发，用着眼线。
St. Greg's was a dumping ground. All the kids kicked out of other Catholic high schools for being bad students or hoodlums wound up at Greg's. These were not kids who instinctively honored diversity. These were kids who beat up sissies.
圣格雷格学校是个垃圾场。所有被其他天主教高中开除的学生，因为是差生或小混混，最终都到了格雷格学校。这些孩子并不是天生尊重多元化的。这些是打倒娘娘腔的孩子。
But no pounding could stop St. Greg's only femme. Like Gandhi he'd be back the day after a beating, defiant in his satin pants with his hair feathered back like Farrah Fawcett's. No punch, no putdown could stop him from talking loudly in the cafeteria about the bars he went to, the men he dated, the trouble he'd seen. He was very femmy, but he didn't want to be a woman. He liked being a guy, and he liked being gay. And he liked everyone to know about it.
但没有任何殴打能阻止圣格雷格学校唯一的女性化男。像甘地一样，他挨打后的第二天就会回来，穿着缎面裤子，头发像法拉·福塞特那样梳着羽毛状发型，依然反叛。没有任何重拳、没有任何贬低能阻止他在食堂大声谈论他去的酒吧、他约会的男人、他见过的麻烦。他非常女性化，但他并不想成为女人。他喜欢做个男人，喜欢做个同性恋。他喜欢让每个人都知道这一点。
As a miserably-closeted 14-year-old sophomore, I desperately wanted to go to gay bars in satin pants. I wanted to date men. I wanted to see some trouble. But I wasn't brave enough or strong enough or courageous enough. This femmy senior, he was all those butch things. He displayed more courage when he walked into St. Greg's every morning than I've ever displayed in my life, which is why I had such a crush on him, I think. Of all the tough kids at St. Greg's, he was absolutely the toughest.
作为一个极度闷骚、14岁的高二学生，我绝望地想穿着缎面裤子去同性恋酒吧。我想和男人约会。我想见识一些麻烦。但我没有足够的勇气、没有足够的坚强、没有足够的胆量。这位女性化的高年级学生，他拥有所有那些刚毅的品质。他每天早上走进圣格雷格学校时展现的勇气，比我一生中展现的任何勇气都要多，我想这就是我为什么那么迷恋他。在圣格雷格学校所有的强硬孩子中，他绝对是最强硬的。
Which brings me, in a rather roundabout fashion, to the personal ads. Being attracted to femmes and willing to admit it makes me something of a rarity among gay men, judging from gay personal ads. No one seems to like femme guys much. In the personals in the Village Voice , the Chicago Reader , and the SF Weekly, almost every other boy seeking a boy winds up his ad with "no fats, no femmes," or the truly appalling "straight-acting, straight-appearing."
这让我以一种相当迂回的方式谈到了个人征友广告。被女性化男性吸引并愿意承认这一点，使我在同性恋人群中显得有点另类，从同性恋征友广告中可以判断出来。似乎没有人喜欢女性化男。在《乡村之声》、《芝加哥读者》和《旧金山周报》的征友启事中，几乎每一个寻求男性的男孩都会在广告结尾写上“不要胖子，不要女性化男”，或者那种真正令人震惊的“直男行为、直男外观”。
What is up with that? I don't have a problem with no fats, no femmes. That's just blunt. But straight-acting and appearing? What does that mean, exactly?
这到底是怎么回事？我并不介意“不要胖子，不要女性化男”。那只是直白。但“直男行为”和“直男外观”？那到底是什么意思？
Straight-acting and appearing guys don't read gay personal ads, do they? Reading gay personals is a very gay-acting to do, and responding to gay personals is a very, very, very gay-acting thing to do, practically the gayest action a man can take short of having gay sex or owning the soundtrack to Yentil.
直男行为和外观的家伙不看同性恋征友广告，对吧？阅读同性恋征友信息是非常“同性恋”的行为，而回应同性恋征友信息是非常、非常、非常同性恋的行为，实际上除了进行同性性行为或拥有《杨朵》的原声带之外，男人能做的最同性恋的行动莫过于此。
When a person, a gay person, puts straight-acting, a straight-appearing in his ad-- and mind you, it's only about 1 out of 10 ads-- he's saying that gayness, in and of itself, is unattractive, undesirable. A few years ago, The Stranger , the paper I work for in Seattle, launched a personals section. Being the sex guy at the paper, the personals became my responsibility. I ran the section and got to decide what was and was not kosher. And the first thing I absolutely forbid was "straight-acting, straight-appearing."
当一个人，一个同性恋者，在他的广告中放上“直男行为”、“直男外观”——请注意，大约只有十分之一的广告会这样——他是在说，同性恋本身是没有吸引力的，不可取的。几年前，我工作的西雅图报纸《Stranger》推出了征友版块。作为报社负责性话题的人，征友信息成了我的责任。我负责管理这个版块，并决定什么是合规的，什么不是。我绝对禁止的第一件事就是“直男行为、直男外观”。
Some of my straight-acting and appearing coworkers, who were also actually straight, objected. Nothing else was banned in our freewheeling personals section. Deleting "straight-acting" reeked of PC censorship. After pitching a hissy fit at a staff meeting, a very gay-acting thing to do, by the way, I got my way.
我的一些直男行为和外观的同事，他们实际上也是直男，提出了异议。在我们自由自在的征友版块里，没有其他东西被禁止。删除“直男行为”带有政治正确审查的味道。在员工会议上大发雷霆（顺便说一句，这是一种非常同性恋的行为）之后，我达成了我的目的。
We wouldn't run ads from a black woman seeking white-acting black men, I remember shouting, or a Jewish guy seeking Christian-appearing Jewish women, would we? Most of my straight-appearing coworkers saw my point, and the rest were willing to let the lone sissy on staff make the call about what was, I told them, a gay thing.
我记得我大声喊道，我们不会刊登一个黑人女性寻求“白人行为”的黑人男性的广告，也不会刊登犹太人寻求“基督徒外观”的犹太女性的广告，会吗？我大部分“直男外观”的同事明白我的观点，其余的人则愿意让员工中唯一的娘娘腔来决定什么是他们所说的“同性恋事情”。
As a result, The Stranger is, so far as I know, the only paper in the country, gay or straight that will not allow gay men to advertise themselves as straight-acting, straight-appearing. Not that something hasn't taken its place. Something has, a monster of my own creation.
结果，《Stranger》据我所知是全国唯一一家无论同性恋还是异性恋，都不允许同性恋男性宣传自己为“直男行为、直男外观”的报纸。并非没有东西取代它。确实有，一个我自己创造的怪物。
You see, at first, if someone sent in a straight-acting ad, we'd run the ad just without the phrase. But sometimes, dropping the phrase left a hole in the ad. So we would very occasionally substitute the word "masculine" for the phrase "straight-acting straight-appearing." The word caught on, and now it's in almost every ad in the boys-seeking-boys section of the Stranger personals.
你看，起初，如果有人发来“直男行为”的广告，我们会删除那个短语刊登广告。但有时，去掉这个短语会在广告中留下空白。所以我们偶尔会用“男性化”这个词代替“直男行为直男外观”这个短语。这个词流行起来了，现在《Stranger》征友版块“男孩寻找男孩”栏目中几乎每个广告都有它。
What you don't see much of in the personals are men looking for femmy guys. And ads placed by guys who admit to being femmy are the rarest of the rare, since admitting to being femme has all the allure of admitting to being a fat slob. Here's an interesting one. "Black male, secure, straight-acting, in the closet, femme, seeking boyfriend." Wow. Coming across this ad made me feel like a bird watcher who just spotted some rare tropical parrot up in the Arctic Circle. A straight-acting femme. How do you pull that off?
你在征友广告中看不到太多男人在寻找女性化的男性。而那些承认自己是女性化男的广告更是稀有中的稀有，因为承认自己是女性化男，就像承认自己是个又胖又邋遢的人一样，没有任何吸引力。这里有一个有趣的广告。“黑人男性，有安全感，直男行为，在柜子里，女性化男，寻找男朋友。”哇。看到这个广告让我感觉像个观鸟者，在北极圈内发现了一只稀有的热带鹦鹉。“直男行为的女性化男”。你怎么做到的？
And here's another ad from a guy who risked describing himself as femmy. "Gay, white male, 5'9", 150 pounds, HIV negative, attractive, mildly feminine, seeks relationship with gay male around six foot." I decided to give him a call. His name is Mark.
还有另一个敢于描述自己为女性化的男人的广告。“同性恋，白人男性，5英尺9英寸，150磅，HIV阴性，有吸引力，略微女性化，寻找与约6英尺高的同性恋男性的关系。”我决定给他打个电话。他的名字叫马克。
When you say "feminine," what are you trying to tell people who read your personal about you?
当你说是“女性化”时，你试图告诉阅读你个人广告的人关于你的什么信息？
I'm not masculine. I'm not straight-acting. And I wanted to clarify that because it sickens me when I read a personal ad and it says, I'm straight-acting.
我不男性化。我不直男行为。我想澄清这一点，因为当我读到个人广告说“我是直男行为”时，我感到恶心。
Why does that bother you?
为什么这让你烦恼？
Because it seems really self-hating, and I'd rather not define myself in terms of the straight culture.
因为这看起来真的很自我厌恶，我宁愿不用异性恋文化的术语来定义自己。
Have you encountered guys who didn't like the fact that you were mildly feminine or guys who wouldn't date you or had negative experiences with guys who freaked out because you listen to Barbra Streisand or something?
你有没有遇到过不喜欢你略微女性化，或者不想和你约会，或者因为你听芭芭拉·史翠珊之类的东西而抓狂的人？
I don't know if I would say I've had negative experiences, but I definitely think that-- well, I'll say that a friend of mine recently said that he thought that I would get more dates if I had a deeper voice.
我不知道我是否会说我有过负面经历，但我肯定认为——嗯，我会说，我的一位朋友最近说，他认为如果我的声音低沉一点，我会约会到更多人。
What does he want you to do? [DEEP VOICE] He wants you to talk like this into the phone?
他想让你做什么？[低沉的声音] 他想让你对着电话这样说话？
[DEEP VOICE] He wants me to talk like this all the time.
[低沉的声音] 他想让我一直这样说话。
And that doesn't sound like it would be you. It doesn't sound like you would be comfortable doing that.
那听起来不像你。那听起来不像你会舒服地做的事情。
No.
不。
But he thinks that you'll get more dates if you do that. Do you think you'll get more dates if you pretend to be butcher than you actually are?
但他认为如果你这样做，你会约会到更多人。你认为如果你假装比你实际更“爷们”，你会约会到更多人吗？
Well, I think that in the gay community, it's something, especially right now, that is desired, unfortunately.
嗯，我认为在同性恋社区，这是某种，尤其是现在，不幸的是，被渴望的东西。
Finally, I decided to call a couple of guys who took out personal ads describing themselves as straight-acting and appearing. I really wanted to know what they thought they were doing when they wrote that down, what they thought it meant to be a straight-acting gay man.
最后，我决定给几个在个人征友广告中描述自己为“直男行为和外观”的男人打电话。我真的很想知道他们在写下那些词时认为自己在做什么，他们认为做一个“直男行为的同性恋男人”意味着什么。
Here's one. "Bodybuilders, let me check you out, tease you, and please you. You be daring closet type. I'm straight-acting closet bi. 30-something, attractive." I'd never spoken to a straight-acting closet bisexual before. I gave him a call.
这是一个。“健美运动员，让我看看你，戏弄你，取悦你。你要是胆大的柜中型。我是直男行为的柜中双性恋。30多岁，有吸引力。”我以前从没和直男行为的柜中双性恋交谈过。我给他打了个电话。
What's straight-acting mean?
什么是直男行为？
Well, definitely not in the gay scene at all. Straight-acting, I go out with women. I have girlfriends occasionally. And I don't think any of my friends would suspect that I have gay sex on the side.
嗯，绝对根本不在同性恋圈子里。直男行为，我和女人出去。我偶尔有女朋友。我认为我没有任何朋友会怀疑我有私下的同性恋性行为。
What if a really sexy-looking guy who looked really butch and really masculine answered your ad, but he had a lisp and was a little effeminate? At what point do you draw the line and say, "You're too effeminate for me"?
如果一个看起来很性感、看起来很“爷们”且非常男性化的家伙回答了你的广告，但他有口吃，而且有点女性化？在什么情况下你会划清界限说，“你对我来说太女性化了”？
It would be a hard to tell you exactly where I would draw the line because it's all such a personal thing. First impressions, when you talk to somebody, and then when you meet them.
很难准确告诉你我会划在哪里，因为这完全是一件个人的事情。第一印象，当你和某人交谈时，然后当你见到他们时。
So if a gay guy who was feminine but could act butch were to respond to your ad, you might think of going out with him so long as the whole time you were together, he could keep it up, he could keep acting sort of straight and appearing straight, even if he went home and put on ladies underwear and listened to Vikki Carr and cried?
所以如果一个女性化但能表现得很“爷们”的同性恋男回应了你的广告，你可能会考虑和他出去，只要你们在一起时，他能保持住，他能保持某种直男行为和直男外观，即使他回家换上女式内衣听着维基·卡尔哭？
That would be perfect.
那太完美了。
You would be OK with that?
你对此没问题？
Yeah.
是的。
Is fear of the consequences of coming out maybe part of what keeps you from being out with everybody?
对出柜后果的恐惧是否可能是让你无法对所有人出柜的部分原因？
Definitely.
绝对是。
What are you afraid might happen?
你担心会发生什么？
Well, I don't want to freak out all my friends, for one thing. Because some of my friends are really pretty conservative.
嗯，首先，我不想让我的朋友们抓狂。因为我的一些朋友相当保守。
Bigoted?
偏执？
Yeah, exactly.
对，正是。
So how does it feel-- I mean, aren't you kind of lying to them? Aren't you like a black person whose best friend is a blind white person who hates black people?
那么感觉如何——我的意思是，你不是在欺骗他们吗？你不是就像一个黑人，他最好的朋友是一个讨厌黑人的盲人白人吗？
I never thought of it that way. I'm not sure I'd agree. It's not like I'm a silent person when things are said and criticisms are made.
我从来没那样想过。我不确定我是否同意。这并不是说当事情被说出来或批评被做出时，我是一个沉默的人。
I saved this next interview for last because, of all the guys who place straight-acting personal ads, the saddest to my mind are the out gay guys who, in every other way, sound pretty together, except that they describe themselves as straight. Robert's ad reads, "Seeking companion of about my age. I am professional, medium build, 37 years old, 6'2", 220 pounds, straight-acting. Looking for a guy for discreet excitement, friendship, and fun."
我把这次采访留到最后，因为在所有投放“直男行为”个人广告的男人中，最让我感到悲哀的是那些出柜的同性恋男人，他们在其他方面看起来都很正常，除了他们描述自己为异性恋。罗伯特的广告写道，“寻找和我年纪差不多的人。我是专业人士，中等身材，37岁，6英尺2英寸，220磅，直男行为。寻找一个男人进行谨慎的刺激、友谊和乐趣。”
When you say you're straight-acting, what do you mean?
当你说是“直男行为”时，你是什么意思？
I just mean that it doesn't fit the traditional stereotype.
我只是说它不符合传统的刻板印象。
That you don't?
你不符合？
Yeah.
对。
What is the traditional stereotype? You describe yourself as a gay man, yeah?
什么是传统的刻板印象？你描述自己是同性恋，对吗？
Right.
对。
But what's the traditional stereotype, that you think you don't fit, of gay men?
但你认为你不符合的同性恋男人的传统刻板印象是什么？
Kind of effeminate.
有点女性化。
Uh huh. What kind of guy are you looking for?
嗯哼。你在寻找什么样的男人？
Just kind of a regular person like I think that I am. I work every day and play hard and just kind of lead a pretty quiet life, and I'm not looking for someone who is doing the--
只是像我认为我那样的普通人。我每天工作，努力玩，过着相当平静的生活，我不是在寻找那种——
The bar thing every night.
每天晚上都去酒吧的那种。
The bar thing, yeah, kind of being burnt out and being promiscuous and things like that.
酒吧那套，对，那种精疲力竭、滥交之类的。
What do you think when you see a really effeminate gay man, like, out in public being really effeminate?
当你看到一个非常女性化的同性恋男人，比如在公共场合表现得非常女性化时，你会怎么想？
I just think, what does he do for a living? If I see him at night, I think it's really fun, and if I see the person during the day, I'm wondering, well, does he have a job? And what do people at work think? Being a member of a minority group, a racial minority, I think that it's really-- I'm just one who are a lot more conservative, and I think that when you label yourself, you make it a lot more difficult.
我只是想，他靠什么生活？如果我晚上见到他，我觉得很有趣；如果我在白天见到他，我心想，好吧，他有工作吗？同事怎么想？作为少数群体的一员，一个种族少数群体，我认为这真的很——我是那种更保守的人，我认为当你给自己贴标签时，会让事情变得困难得多。
When you were a little boy, were you a sissy?
当你是个小男孩时，你是娘娘腔吗？
Yeah, my voice didn't mature fast enough for me.
是的，我的声音发育得不够快。
Were you picked on?
你被欺负了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Do you think that that being picked on had any impact on your adult choices around being very, very private?
你认为那种被欺负对你成年后关于非常、非常隐私的选择有影响吗？
Yes, I do. I do. You want to stay inside of the box. And being inside of the male box, then people are not going to pick on you. People are not going to do mean things and say horrible things about you as long as you stay within a realm of acceptable behavior.
是的，确实。是的。你想呆在盒子里。只要呆在男性化的盒子里，人们就不会欺负你。只要你保持在可接受的行为范围内，人们就不会做卑劣的事情，也不会说关于你的可怕的事情。
So part of what keeps you inside that realm of acceptable behavior, then, is fear of being picked on or being--
所以保持在可接受行为范围内的一部分，是因为害怕被欺负或被——
Labeled.
贴标签。
Labeled or a victim of anti-gay violence. But it's fear, then, at least partially.
贴标签或成为反同性恋暴力的受害者。但这是恐惧，至少部分是。
Yeah.
是的。
So in a way, when you see someone really swishy on the street, isn't that brave of them?
所以从某种意义上说，当你看到街上有个动作非常女性化的人时，这难道不勇敢吗？
Not always. It depends on where the person's coming from. I don't think that if you're swishy and you happen to be in a ghetto of other gay men, then you're free to do that. But I don't think that you're exceptionally brave. I just think that you live in a very violent world, and things happen. And you try not to put yourself into a situation that bad things can happen to you.
不总是。这取决于那个人的背景。我不认为如果你是女性化男，并且刚好在其他同性恋男人的聚居区，那你就自由地做那件事了。但我认为你并不是特别勇敢。我只是认为你生活在一个非常暴力的世界里，事情总会发生。你努力不把自己置于会发生坏事的境地。
I don't agree with Robert. The way I see it, the bravest of all the guys I talked to was Mark, the guy who described himself as feminine in his personal ad. Mark and that brave swishy senior I had a crush on at St. Greg's, they both have the courage to present their real selves to the world in all their glorious sissiness, which, in a world that despises feminine men and boys, is a risky thing to do, a brave thing to do.
我不同意罗伯特的观点。在我看来，我谈过的所有男人中最勇敢的是马克，那个在广告中描述自己为“女性化”的男人。马克和我年轻时迷恋的那个勇敢的女性化高年级学生，他们都有勇气向世界展示真实的自己，展现他们光荣的“娘娘腔”特质。在一个蔑视女性化男人和男孩的世界里，这是一件冒险的事，一件勇敢的事。
Now, contrast their behavior with that of men who are straight-acting, 100% discreet, and in the closet, or men who are constantly policing their own behavior. These are men ruled by fear-- fear of discovery, fear of femininity, fear of what it means to be who they are. They are the sissies.
现在，将他们的行为与那些“直男行为”、100%谨慎且在柜子里的男人，或者不断监管自己行为的男人进行对比。这些是被恐惧统治的男人——害怕被发现，害怕女性化，害怕成为他们自己意味着什么。他们才是真正的娘娘腔。
I'm not saying that the closet case who asks gay men not to respond to his ad needs to be a big, swishy queen in order to be true to himself. He just needs to be a man, secure about who he is, a man who isn't ruled by fear, a man willing to show himself to the world. He needs to not be such a sissy.
我不是说，那个要求同性恋不要回应他广告的“柜中人”为了对自己忠诚，就需要成为一个大大的、女性化的皇后。他只需要做一个男人，对自己的身份有安全感，一个不被恐惧统治的男人，一个愿意向世界展示自己的男人。他需要不再做一个娘娘腔。
Dan Savage. He's the editor at The Stranger , and he has a book coming out in September called The Commitment.
丹·萨维奇。他是《Stranger》的编辑，他有一本九月份出版的书，书名叫《承诺》。
Today's program was produced by Nancy Updike and myself with Peter Clowney, Alix Spiegel, and special guest producer Danny Miller, contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin.
今天的节目由南希·厄普代克和我制作，彼得·克罗尼、阿里克斯·斯皮格尔参与，特邀制片人丹尼·米勒，编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林共同参与。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
And a very special thanks to Mubarak and Margie for letting us, our program, and Nancy Updike into their lives. In the years since we first broadcast their story, Margie passed away in 1998 with Mubarak at her side, holding her hand and talking to her in the hospital when she had her final stroke. Mubarak is currently the editor of the Express Gay News , the gay and lesbian newspaper in Fort Lauderdale, Florida.
特别感谢穆巴拉克和玛姬让我们，让我们的节目，让南希·厄普代克进入他们的生活。自我们首次播出他们的故事以来的几年里，玛姬于1998年去世，穆巴拉克一直守在她身边，在医院她最后一次中风时，握着她的手和她说话。穆巴拉克目前是佛罗里达州劳德代尔堡同性恋报纸《Express Gay News》的编辑。
Margie, I do a pretty good imitation of you. This is what I was telling Mubarak. OK, now I'm imitating myself asking a question. "So, Margie, you said that? And what did Sabir say?" "Nothing. He just looked at me." Isn't that pretty good?
玛姬，我模仿你模仿得挺好的。我就是这么跟穆巴拉克说的。好了，现在我在模仿我自己问问题。“所以，玛姬，你说过那话吗？萨比尔说了什么？”“什么也没说。他只是看着我。”这不错吧？
That's real good. It's good.
那真的很好。很好。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free. Or you can download episodes of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife. WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who explains, no, no, no, he does not laugh like this.
我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们的节目。或者你可以在 audible.com/thisamericanlife 下载我们的节目剧集。WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他解释说，不，不，不，他不会像这样笑。
[HIGH-PITCHED LAUGH]
[尖细的笑声]
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
We won't be staying here. It's far too foofy.
我们不会留在这里。这太花哨了。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。